there's this guy
i wanted to mention from uh i think
south florida
he's a real estate online real estate
guru and he posted a video on his
instagram his name's grant cardone he's
a complete lunatic
is he he's a con man grant cardone is
a used car salesman and in fact when i
was selling used cars
there were two guys that have videos and
seminars for car salesmen one of them is
grant cardone
he is like the he's like
whatever yeah he's grant code sales
courses right yes
yeah and and investing other people's
money
and reits real estate and which people
can invest into commercial real estate
and get the benefits of it
yeah and anyway
uh yeah people like him he this is
clearwater
is where he comes and where he gives his
money to
and this is a massive
uh source of revenue for it's the
biggest source of revenue for
scientology
in the world like
this and everything else in scientology
doesn't add up to
the revenue that a stream of clearwater
he posted this this
continuous instagram story throughout
like a 24-hour period
of him flying on his jet to clear water
taking a limo from clearwater to some
pet house on include like on
in uh downtown clearwater and then he
filmed going through that building
on fort harrison and it looks like like
[ __ ] taj mahal it's a gold plated
everything it's just
so over the top i never would expected
that the inside of that building would
have looked like that
well that's what happens when you've got
unlimited money i mean
scientology has so much money they don't
know what to spend it on
literally and it's actually a problem
for scientology
because they have exempt status they are
supposed to
not accumulate too much
available cash the theory of exemption
is
you're not going to pay taxes because
you're providing a benefit to the public
that the government would otherwise have
to provide
that's the fundamental theory of tax
exemption that's why
religious and educational organizations
etc
are tax-exempt because they are doing
something
that is for the public benefit and the
public good so do they have to spend
this money on certain things they are
supposed to
they're supposed to but they're not
technically regulated no
they're not regulated at all but they're
worried about being regulated and that's
why you see
scientology spend so much money on real
estate
the only thing that scientology spends
its money on
is real estate because they can argue
that this is necessary
for the propagation of the religion
even though the buildings are empty you
know they've got this place over in
tampa that's
empty they've got one in orlando that's
empty they've got one in miami that's
empty
huge buildings that they spend tens tens
of millions of dollars
to put together because they have to
spend their money on something
and so you see the inside of that that
building in
in clearwater it's because of that they
got unlimited money they've got three
billion dollars in cash and they have to
figure out how to spend it so
it gets spent on real estate and
you know the the issue with clearwater
is that because there is so
much already invested in clearwater by
scientology
and because it is the revenue stream
that keeps the whole operation
flush it's going to be protected
at all costs and part of protecting it
is to build a perimeter
around it that is
not occupied by wogs and wogs is the
derogatory scientology term
for non-scientologists they would like
nothing more like harry potter then all
of
clearwater downtown to be
scientology surrounded by a moat of
nothing
so there's no one that can be looking in
on their buildings there's no one that's
pestering them there's no one that's
seeing
alisa mcpherson you know freaking out in
the
in the window there's no no
oversight no intrusion of the outside
world
into the world of scientology and
that's why you see
downtown clearwater basically owned now
by scientology
and i don't know how
clearwater is ever going to deal with it
the only
way that it could possibly happen would
be for
scientology to lose its tax-exempt
status
and then it wouldn't matter to downtown
clearwater see scientology loves to
claim
we're the largest taxpayers in downtown
clearwater
yeah that's true you pay like
two million dollars in taxes a year and
if you were not
exempt you'd be paying a hundred million
dollars in taxes a year
they pay taxes on hotels like
spaces that they use for hotels not the
religious buildings right but the hotels
so only the religious buildings are tax
exempt yeah but they
they claim most of them are religious
buildings okay so
that's what i mean it's like you know
maybe one they pay one-tenth of what
they would otherwise
have to pay you know so but for some
for one reason or another because of
their size it still ends up being more
than anybody else in clearwater yeah
i mean there there isn't anything else
in downtown clearwater really otherwise
buildings there's a starbucks down there
yeah well that was brought there by me
that's about it
was it really me and tom devocked
because david muscavich
that's a long story
[Laughter]
i walk into that starbucks you know what
happens if i walk into that starbucks
danny what
all the customers leave why because
all the customers in there virtually all
them are scientologists
really yes if i walk down the street in
clearwater
they're empty what they all know who you
are i go to nature's food patch
people like i love nature's food patch
that's my favorite place
really full of even that work there are
just the employ or just their customers
mostly customers mostly customers yeah
lots of scientologists wild
dude oh my god we have to can we do that
danny you know you film you
i went i went to um the movie theater
the the uh the 21
theaters on tampa road and colu whatever
that is out there
the cobb one no anyway i went to the
movie theater
i walked in there with my wife and
actually it was to see
paul haggis movie the three days or
whatever it was
i walked in there and in the front row
were six
sea org members i walked in
i sat down they got up and left
they walked out of the movie because
they didn't want to be in the same
theater as me that is so bizarre man
that is so [ __ ] bizarre
i have great power you do have great
power you're a wizard
and i have the power of the sp
the sp